so he has a 95% on Rotten Tomatoes we'll
see if it lives up to the height
American hustle so American hustles
directed by David O'Russell he's the
director of the fighter and silver
linings playbook really like both of
those movies now he's doing a hustle
movie this is a movie about scams
hustling you know con artists in America
I guess cuz that's what the title says
Christian Bale and Amy Adams play a
couple of con artists and Bradley Cooper
gets involved with them because he's an
FBI agent and then they're gonna scam a
bunch of people and lock him up more
[ __ ] happens in this movie among the web
of overly inflated story arcs that's
really what you need to know it'll be
clear this movie had a lot going for it
all the performances kicked ass and
really none of the actors need any
introduction you know all of them by
name and you know they all are great
Christian Bale Amy Adams Bradley Cooper
Jeremy Renner Jennifer Lawrence hell
Louis CK's in this movie at one point I
was awesome I love that dude he's one of
my favorite comedians in my opinion the
thing that carries this movie the reason
it's so hailed among everybody is
because every actor in this movie played
their part and they played it wow that
may have really good dialogue I don't
know if some of the dialogue was
ad-libbed it looks so natural among the
actors that you're like I had to have
been ad-lib but maybe not maybe the
script and the actors just works out
well together
I wouldn't surprise me because David
O'Russell has worked with these people
before us though he's like I know you I
know how you are here here's a script
written just for you it's a hustle that
whole culture is just interesting to me
pathological crazy people who were just
like I am going to [ __ ] my way
through life make people believe
something I'm gonna take him for
whatever one thing to be said about
David or Russell he likes weirdos he
likes people who are off just a bit
crazies all this movies have [ __ ] like
that however there is a fine line
between passion project and ego trip I
think this movie teetered a bid on the
David O'Russell ego trip side rather
than passion project this movie felt
really inflated granted as a Khan movie
it's going to have a lot of plot twists
and turns I get that [ __ ] I'm just
saying there were too many people in
this movie this movie concentrated for
too long on too many people and it's
attracted from the movie I get the
feeling that David O'Russell was like I
have worked with all these people I'm
going to make a super movie that can
have all of them in it and they're all
going to get their time to shine cool if
you do that you're going to detract from
the movie as a whole you got to know
that
Christian Bale's wife played by Jennifer
Lawrence cool everyone loves Jennifer
Lawrence I love Jennifer Lawrence how
long did the movie actually have to
concentrate on Christian Bale's wife
seriously when Jennifer Lawrence is like
dancing around like waving her head like
this and [ __ ] scrubbing her counters
you're like and this movie is a comedy I
know that because it's nominated for a
Golden Globe for Best Comedy but if I
didn't know it was a comedy because it
was nominated for a comedy I would just
think it's a hustle movie that has
really awkward moments in it scene where
Bradley Cooper's beating someone over
the head with a phone violently you're
like it's supposed to be funny because
of how it's edited but again if you
didn't know it was a comedy he'd be like
that's weirdly and awkwardly edited to
look funny when it's just an [ __ ]
being violent and he's being a dick
however this movie does have a really
cool end to it in a hustle movie in a
scam movie you got to have a cool ending
this movie does have a solid ending I'm
just saying among the great acting and
really good dialogue the path to getting
to that ending was so inflated and so
much [ __ ] happens I don't think needed
to happen in the movie no one's gonna
say this is a bad movie it's not a bad
movie I just think if this movie focused
up its point it would have been brought
on course and would have been a little
better in the end I will say American
hustle is overhyped as [ __ ] but I will
say it is a good time no alcoholics
wired it so American hustle have you
sittin what did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you